right excellent I'm a fan thank you man
likewise congrats on all your success oh
thanks I'll get canceled eventually but
right now
I believe that there's this thing in New
York comedy where you guys are almost
like aggressively
just like trying to be over the line
well that's the weird thing is we're not
we're just doing what we think is funny
but we had Louie Gomez oh well maybe him
he's he's got a knife at your throat as
a comedian but uh I don't I just like
silly stupid dick jokes and right Asian
people are weird or whatever you know
that's just funny so yeah and then the
world changed we never changed that's
the weird part the world got all queefy
and sensitive and twittery but I'm still
the same comic yeah yeah but I feel when
you go to like Portland people love it I
love it because they go they swing back
because uh they're known for being
crunchy and annoying yeah so they
overcompensate by like jizz in my ass
you know they want it hard yeah then
when you go to Florida they're like what
the [ __ ] yeah no I don't think Florida
is an anyway sensitive at all no no no
you can wave a gun on stage like when
Michael Richards did his thing Florida
was like bring him over here well watch
that yeah he has a residency in Florida
yeah I bet he would sell out in a
heartbeat I'd go to see that I I wonder
I was just thinking about him where is
he in LA or is he in New York he's in La
living off that pile of Seinfeld sitcom
cash yeah they just got picked up by
Netflix so they're probably doing pretty
good I wonder uh
oh The Supporting Cast did in like the
pile of cash departure oh are you
kidding me yeah come on they call it
sitcom heaven when you make it into that
uh syndication syndication yeah yeah so
and then Hulu bought it Netflix bought
it that just keeps going DVD sales
forget about it right yeah I gotta
believe that that's the case do you see
stuff come in when you get on Netflix or
jackass or not even
um oh yeah I think so yeah for the
movies yeah we we got like a little
slippers of back-end participation so uh
when when the movie makes money we get a
little taste a little sniff oh yeah you
could tell I think it's like the older
movies it's like you know almost it's
not like funny small amounts of money
right it's not let's not like wow what
about like uh like jackass TV show isn't
that in this indication all over the
world different deal like uh for the TV
show it was just like yeah you're a
[ __ ] we're gonna put you on TV you get
nothing you know that's the problem with
jackass though is you guys there's like
38 of you you know every time I watch
I'm like oh yeah that guy but you know
it's Steve-O bam uh Johnny Pontius you
know the the hardcore crew but there's
always a couple of was it Englert
England England yeah yeah that guy the
fat guy um Preston and his Wee Man so
there's so many of you it's like a giant
it's like the Boss Tones like how do you
guys all get a paycheck after this
concert right it's called Stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole and if you go on
Amazon and type in Stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and Order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now now we're at ranked
number 30 on all of Amazon and if you
buy a bottle we might go up the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on Amazon and buy Stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole yeah
yeah dude